hi it's Michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry PhD skincare nerd and
not very proud owner of some clog tastic
skin today we're talking about comedogenicity
or how ingredients make your
skin break out if you like this sort of
video give this video a thumbs up
subscribe to my channel and make sure
you click the notification button so you
don't miss out on any of my videos i'm
going to be saying comedogenicity of
lush and it's not an easy word to say so
please forgive me as i butcher it you've
probably seen charts with comedogenic
ingredients like this one before they
rate different ingredients on their
ability to cause pimples what you're
meant to do is check the ingredients
list of your product against this list
if it has highly comedgenic
ingredients it will cause pimples if it
doesn't then it won't it's simple
systematic and foolproof but is this
system actually backed up by science
comedogenicity is the tendency of
an ingredient or product to clog pores
ingredients are ranked on a scale zero
means that something is completely non
comedogenic one means that it's slightly
comedogenic two to three means it's
moderately comedogenic and four to five
means it's going to break you the hell
out the numbers in these scales
generally come from studies performed by
scientific researchers and they've been
published in peer-reviewed journals this
usually means that they're somewhat
reliable and valid but just like a lot
of other claims in skincare that are
supported by the research you don't
really see the full story until you dig
a bit deeper so what's wrong with this
scale
the problem is that the studies that
produce these ratings don't actually
reflect what happens when you use these
ingredients in skin care products for a
lot of reasons firstly the tests often
aren't done in real-world conditions in
an ideal world we test every single
product on every single person's face
and then we develop a really definitive
list of what will and won't break you
out
but this would be impossible it would
cost too much there's way too many
products to try and everyone's face and
getting a lot of people to use just one
product and not change their daily
routine for weeks or months at a time
this would just wouldn't happen instead
what's used in a scientific study is a
model a situation that mimics the
real-world situation but it's going to
be a lot simpler to carry out and
control and interpret there's lots of
examples of scientific models things
like crash test dummies samples of hair
that get dyed
pouring liquid onto sanitary pads patch
testing things on your arm
testing bikes on a racetrack most of the
time these models work pretty well but
usually they don't have everything that
would happen in real life so you can't
just apply their results really
straightforwardly to everyday life in
other words the external validity can be
questionable when we're talking about
comedogenicity ratings the models
aren't that great the most common tests
for comedogenicity is the rabbit ear
model this was pioneered in cosmetics
testing by two really famous
dermatologists Albert Kligman and James
Fulton this happened in the 1970s what
the rabbit ear model was was you apply
the substance to the inner ear of a
rabbit and then you wait a few weeks and
see if you get any clogged pores or comedones
rabbit ears are a lot more
sensitive than human skin so they
react to these ingredients much faster
which was really convenient
the problem is there's lots of false
positives so ingredients that aren't
comedogenic in humans would be in a
rabbit ear
in the original test there was another
problem rabbit ears have naturally
enlarged pores and some of the earlier
results countered these bigger pores as
acne which meant there were even more
false positives so in other words there
were ingredients that people thought
were really comedogenic even though
it was just an experimental error the
most famous false positive is petroleum
jelly which is also known as petrolatum
the only ingredient in Vaseline this
false positive was corrected in the late
1980s but whether or not it was
comedogenic was debated until the mid
1990s this wasn't the first time that
the rabbit ear model had problems there
were usually lots of conflicting results
and that's why lots of these comedogenic
ingredient lists disagree with each
other
more recently in 2007 two dermatologists
wrote the rabbit ear model is unable to
accurately depict the acnegenic
potential of chemical compounds and is
therefore only valuable for
distinguishing absolute negatives in
other words the rabbit ear model can
only tell us about what things are
really really unlikely to cause clogged
pores if rabbit ears don't reflect what
happens on human skin then the obvious
solution is to try it on human skin but
again we got more problems firstly in
human skin tests they usually use the
skin on people's backs the problem is
back skin is different from face skin so
for example your face skin has a lot
more hair follicles and it's exposed to
a lot more sunlight that means that
whether your back and your face react the
same way to ingredients is pretty
questionable human tests also use people
with large pores who are more prone to
getting pimples will someone with small
pores react the same way to these
ingredients most of the time the way
that these tests are conducted is that
the ingredient that's being tested is
swabbed onto your skin and then they
cover it with a bandage this isn't
typically what you do with skin care if
you cover an ingredient what happens is
you have greater penetration which means
that you're more likely to get pimples
so think about things like when you have
clothing rubbing against your skin
this can cause pimples the human tests
also done a relatively small sample
usually it's less than 10 people and so
again there's the problem where it might
not be so reliable you might not get the
same result if you test it on 10 other
people or on a hundred people or a
thousand people so again how useful
these ratings are whether we can apply
them in our everyday usage of skin care
products and cosmetics it's been pretty
overstated another huge issue with these
comedogenic ingredients is that even if
an ingredient is comedogenic on its own
it might not be once you put it into a
product and even if a product doesn't
have any comedogenic ingredients it can
still cause pimples when you put it on
your skin there's a saying in biology
which is the dose makes the poison so
for example if you breathe in humid air
it doesn't kill you and it's actually
quite nice but if you breathe in too
much water like in the ocean then you
drown drinking one glass of wine is
probably fine but 10 glasses will give
you a massive hangover 50 glasses will
probably kill you so how much you have
of an ingredient makes a huge difference
to your skin and clogged pores work this
way as well here's the quote from a 1996
paper from Kligman substances that are
strongly comedogenic when tested
neat which means by itself or in high
concentrations become non comedogenic
after sufficient dilution for example in
a study published in 2006
100% pure acetylated lanolin alcohol
gave a really high comedogenic rating of
4 to 5 a 50% it was still 4 to 5 but
when it was diluted to 25% it became a
rating of 1 most skin care products
contain lots and lots of different
ingredients and most of them are well
below 25% and if they're diluted by that
much they might not have the same effect
so a typical face lotion moisturizer has
80% water which means that all of the
other ingredients will max out at 20%
and that's if you only have one other
ingredient in your product the same
study also found that products which had
notable comedogenic ingredients with 4
to 5 ratings things like cocoa butter
isopropyl palmitate and isopropyl isostearate
they didn't actually increase the
formation of microcomedones which
are baby pimples
there's also a 1989 paper that found
extra combination effects ingredients
that were mixed together would sometimes
be more comedogenic than the single
ingredients and sometimes less what the
ingredient was dissolved in can also
make a difference so here's another
quote from Albert Kligman who pioneered
this scale one cannot determine from a
reading of the ingredients whether a
given product will be acnegenic or not
what matters solely is the behavior of
the product itself so even the person
who invented this scale said flat out
that it shouldn't be used to screen an
ingredients list and on top of all of
this there's even more considerations
that you should be aware of your unique
skin chemistry partially tells you
whether or not something will become
comedogenic or not even in the scientific
experiments the same ingredient in the
same procedure gave different results on
different people there are lots of
reasons this could be the case you might
have different bacteria on your skin a
different skin microbiome you might have
different activity levels you might get
exposed to different environmental
conditions and of course there's always
genetics the source of the ingredient
can also change how likely it is that it'll
break you out so for example with
natural extracts there's lots of
variation in what chemicals are in
particular batches so all of this means
that you can't just check the
ingredients list against one of these
comedogenic rating lists and expect that
to tell you how acnegenic something is
so what does all of this mean it means
that these comedogenicity scales are
only useful in very limited
circumstances so the first case is
narrowing down what might be causing
your breakouts if you're breaking out
and you're not sure which product is
causing it then checking for really
comedogenic ingredients like four to
five ratings high up on an ingredients
list might help you look in the right
direction if you have a product and it
has no comedogenic ingredients then it's
less likely to be the culprit but it
could still be so it's important to
remember that this is only a starting
point and it's not conclusive at all if
your skin is really sensitive to
clogging
then it might be worth avoiding products
with large amounts of comedogenic
ingredients if you're really acne prone
and there's a product which has a bunch
of really comedogenic ingredients high
up in the list then it's probably a good
idea to avoid the product or patch
test really carefully before you keep
using it if you're already using a
product and it's been fine don't stop
using it just because you see that its
ingredients match what's high up on this
scale what happens in the real world on
your individual skin is much more
important than what happens
theoretically another case where these
ratings might actually be useful is if
you're trying to avoid undiluted
comedogenic ingredients and you don't
want to patch test
there are a few ingredients that are
commonly used without dilution so things
like natural oils and butters these
ratings can help you navigate these a
little bit coconut oil for example is
rated a fall on this scale which means
it's pretty comedogenic but lots and
lots of people still use it with no
problems if your skin is pretty prone to
breakouts then you might want to patch
test it and proceed with caution or you
might want to try a less comedogenic
ingredient first note that you can't
really use the fatty acid profile of an
oil to work out how comedogenic the
final oil is the fatty acids are
reactive before they're put into the oil
so they don't work the same way so what
you shouldn't do with these ratings
lists you shouldn't go on a witch hunt
and chuck out any products that have
comedogenic ingredients you shouldn't
avoid a product that otherwise sounds
good just because it contains a comedo
genic ingredient you shouldn't bother
looking up an ingredient beyond the
first five or so and even five is sort
of pushing it it'll be really dilute by the
time it's after the first five
ingredients you also shouldn't use these
ratings as a shortcut to avoid patch
testing new products again even if it
doesn't have comedogenic ingredients it
can still break you out so that's it for
this video I hope you liked it if you
did please give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to my channel for more videos
like this you can also follow me on
Instagram and check out my blog if you
like beauty science leave me a comment
letting me know what else you want me to
talk about and see you next time for
more beauty science